all right this video we're gonna talk
about the profiles tab of chrome
developer tools this is an awesome tab
and an awesome tool it helps you really
understand the execution time and memory
usage of your whole webpage or app so
the way you can do it you can collect
these profiles or snapshots you can do a
JavaScript CPU profile which just goes
through the execution time for the
JavaScript the heap snapshot which is
how the memory is distributed through
your pages javascript object and dom
nodes which is it describes to you on
here and the record heap allocation so
it's all the JavaScript options over
time if there's a memory leak
something's going on with memory leaks
this heap allocations a place to do that
let's just start with the JavaScript
profile we're gonna start that let's
refresh the page so it has some fun data
to work with and we will stop it keeps
the profile over here so let's do
another one real quick I want a heap
snap snapshot it does it just in a
second the snapshot and then a heap a
location I'm gonna start refresh the
page and stop so I've got all I've got
these three profile types those took me
a second so the profile one which is a
CPU profile it's set you up with a lot
of information just like all these tabs
if anything overwhelms me it's that
there's so much data I just don't know
what to do with it or when I need to
look at it remember you're going to be
using this when you're trying to figure
out where memory is going in execution
time but there's a lot of tabs that have
to do with execution time this one is
pretty specific for memory as well so
you can look at this information a
couple different ways in a chart which
is really nice graphical allocation if
you had some data that took a little bit
longer that might be more useful but
again it's whatever works for you
all right so let's look at it bottom-up
that's what works best for me but you've
got to find what works best for you so
let's see this has got a yellow
exclamation point by it it's got a let's
see what it says compile nodes ok so
there's a lot going on here if we click
this first one we can see what file it's
in and where it's in in the JavaScript
exactly what's happening ok so here we
go
this is exactly what
was talking about when we were looking
at the profile which i think is really
cool so luckily here there was nothing
that seemed to take a ton of time
everything here seems to be running
pretty smoothly but if that's not the
case with your page and you're finding
something taking a lot of memory this is
where it will show up and you can find
exactly where it is in your code that
has the problem all these tools are
meant to help you in the process of not
only just developing from the beginning
but maintaining your webpage if
something breaks if something starts to
not act right it will save you a lot of
time just finding exactly what's wrong
let's take a look real quick of these
snapshots it's a little bit different so
this just says all the different
elements that make up a document object
model treat all the things that are in
HTML CSS again so much information it's
okay to not understand it all ones I
don't understand it all yet but knowing
it's there and familiarizing yourself
with the language that they're using and
how you can organize the information
when the time comes that you do need to
use it you'll know where to look and
you'll know what's possible with these
tools